[Musique]
venise ce fut pendant 48 heures des îles
parmi les îles et palais les églises et
les ponts devenant chacun à venise
autonome subissent en outre âge sans
faiblir prêt à survivre pour témoigner
sol de la république
la vraie celle de venise pour la
première fois en effet un ouvrage de la
république a failli céder la digue de
palestrina le bastion des doges
consolidé par napoléon pour la première
fois en me lançant certains points n'a
pas résisté à la tempête
[Musique]
oh
aujourd'hui on nettoie on jette on solde
on vit comme on a toujours fait
seulement cette fois ci ce fut un peu
plus fort un peu plus tragique un peu
plus angoissante d'habitude nous sommes
chaque année avec lots et chaque fois
quant aux 120 et nous recommençons nous
sommes ravis des lots et des fois elle
est ennemi et nous la chose de brut
arrive cette fois c'est que depuis neuf
siècles elle est remontée à une eau
terre et nord est m 70 sur les niveaux
alors cette chose incroyable il ya pas
de philosophie
enore benda bilili c'est la même
philosophie qui ne fait au fond bien aux
autres quand vous leur posez quand même
même si l'eau monte des 9 et 10
[Musique]
oh
qui
[Musique]
mon
pendant ce temps là
le gouvernement de la république moderne
celle là celle de monsieur sarr agathe
prend les dispositions qui s'imposent
210 milliards de lires pour les premiers
travaux afin que ça ne se reproduise
plus les italiens perron le tabac et les
sens plus cher pour venir en aide aux
sinistrés
et puis pas ce qu'ils disent
venise s'enfonce doucement dans la
lagune millimètre par millimètre et
aussi ce n'est plus un problème italien
mais internationale comme le sauvetage
des temples de nubie parce que c'est
trop cher
les vénitiens répondent laisser dire
venise résistera plus longtemps que
n'importe quoi à la folie des hommes
[Musique]